hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast impact of the cobas Liette
flew a say on clinical decision making
in the emergency department claims study
group I am Brenda Kelly Kim elaborate
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's webcast is presented by
lab routes comm the leading social media
site for science professionals and
sponsored by roche diagnostics as a
global leader in health care roche
diagnostics offers a broad portfolio of
tools that help healthcare providers in
the early detection prevention diagnosis
and treatment of diseases in molecular
diagnostics we are driven by a vision of
working with laboratories like yours to
improve the medical value you offer in
microbiology infectious diseases
oncology and genomics we continue to
meet unmet needs through our investment
in research innovation and scientific
excellence with the goal of supporting
your important role in patients lives
before we start we have a few
instructions one hear from you during
this interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment answers
welcome to you can do this by hitting
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window and typing in
your comments and questions we'll try to
get to as many as we can and my
follow-up if we don't have time today
want a better look you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button on the
top right or use the Q&A button and
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues now let's get right to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome dr.
Glenn Hanson dr. Hanson is the director
of clinical microbiology and molecular
diagnostics at Hennepin County Medical
Center in Minneapolis Minnesota and an
assistant professor in the Department of
laboratory medicine
pathology and department of medicine at
the University of Minnesota he is an
active member of the American Society
for Microbiology the Academy of Clinical
Laboratory physicians and scientists the
Association for molecular pathology the
association of medical microbiology and
infectious diseases of Canada and the
infectious disease Society of America
dr. Hansen to you about influenza may be
kind of strange to be talking about the
flu season during summer but we know
that the influenza outbreaks that we see
every year clearly crossed two areas of
the country and time frames in which
we've seen influenza outbreaks so I'm
happy to be with you today to talk to
you about our experience with a new
diagnostic test in our emergency
department last year so with that I like
to send my appreciation to lab roots and
the invitation for being here today I
have one disclosure some of the data
that we're going to show you today was
supported by an unrestricted edge
investigator-initiated unrestricted
educational grant from roche to generate
some of the data that we use in our
emergency department last year so the
purpose of today's talk is really to
look at five distinct areas to discuss
why influenza is always a discussion for
both clinical laboratory communities and
hospital networks each year why do we
continue to hear issues about influenza
what options are available for testing
in influenza series rapid test molecular
test panel tests where do these new
diagnostic frontiers capture in the
clinical diagnostic community and there
is a new option for influenza testing
this year that we'd like to introduce
you to two test system that we had some
experience with last year called the
Roche Co basquiat that will introduce
you to but beyond that really what we're
going to focus on here today is the
theoretical question of whether or not
testing can impact patient management
particularly in the emergency department
setting and share with you some of our
experiences we like to think as
laboratory ins that the testing that we
offer has a direct impact to patient
care so we'd like to explore that
discussion a little further and finally
to talk about testing and impacting
outcomes in this modern day of
healthcare management where we spend our
money and how we spend our money wisely
with diagnostic tests that can really
impact outcome of patients is a key area
of discussion going forward so with that
I'd like to introduce you to the
influenza virus each year we get
influenza that occurs indistinct
outbreaks varying extent every year the
epidemiological pattern of the influenza
reflects the changes in nature's of
antigen etic properties of the virus and
the subsequent spread and virulence that
we see each year of influenza is
directly related to some of the
transmissibility properties as these
virus shift so every year as laboratory
and communities we gear up for flu
season we talk about extending coverage
of testing to help our healthcare
systems we look at it and typically when
we talk about influenza we'll see a
figure like this that is put up here a
schematic of the virus and we know that
each year influenza remains a moving
target both for Diagnostics as well as
therapeutic as well as vaccine
development because we know our virus
shifts we know that the antigen etic
properties of the virus the virulence
that we see the diagnostic capabilities
of detecting the virus are often
dependent on changes that we see in
surface proteins particularly
hemagglutinin and neuraminidase changes
to hemagglutinin allow different viruses
to bind to silac acid receptors on
epithelial cells in different fashions
we know that our molecular tests target
largely matrix proteins inside the virus
but it's those changes to the virus each
year that give us some of the discussion
points going forward to talk about
influenza when we see my small minor
changes small minor mutational events
that occur in the virus we refer to
those as antigen etic drift when we see
large reassortment of the viruses and
the so-called terminologies that we hear
h1n1 is example h1n 5 when we see large
reassortment of the viruses within human
and animal communities then we refer to
that as antigen etic antigen etic
and all of these properties come
together to allow us to be able to look
at the way in which we treat patients
diagnose and and protect patients
against influenza every year whoops I
went back slide so moving forward it's
interesting to note that this is a slide
published last year in MMWR looking at
the influenza rates the epidemic rates
that we had seen over the last five
years when we calculate epidemic
thresholds epidemiologists will look at
mortality rates of the virus as
represented by largely 1.6 standard
deviations above a mortality rate that
represents a threshold and what you can
see is that over the last four or five
seasons we've had distinct patterns in
which the influenza season has reached
epidemic thresholds this puts tremendous
pressure both on health care communities
health care systems as well as
diagnostic labs to meet the demand for
incoming flu seasons we know that
incidence rates this is some of our own
local data provided to us by our great
state Department of Health in the state
of Minnesota looking at some of the
incidence rates that we had seen over
the last few years last year in
particular 2014-2015 was a particularly
large year for the state of Minnesota
and many of you have had similar
experiences where you get calls from
emergency department from pediatric
settings saying that we're seeing a lot
of flu so the theoretical questions of
why tests for flu often come up and
we're going to circle round to this but
we do hear these discussions during the
height of flu season if a patient
presents an emergency department or to
an outpatient clinic with signs of fever
and signs of symptoms of influenza it's
probably influenza why do we need to
test for flu and these are just some of
the issues this discussion points to
talk about we know that testing for flu
can help guide treatment courses we know
that antibiotics are often over
administered in cases when they
shouldn't be and we want to be able to
be judicious in the use of antivirals
that we provide for upcoming flu seasons
the CDC has numerous recommend
recommendations for who gets antiviral
treatment and there's large debate over
these we know that over the years there
have been some debates over who gets the
antiviral treatments what
cohorts should we look at it for we
truthfully probably don't give enough
antivirals to patients that we see but
you can see some of the populations that
we see here severe are complicated
courses those requiring hospitalization
those at extreme age groups long-term
care facilities amino suppressive
therapies those of specific ethnic
origins these are all recommendations by
the CDC to help guide treatment for flu
we also know that testing definitively
for flu can help support empiric
antibiotic coverage for admitted
patients we hope that it can help guide
admission and discharge changes in
orders and we hope that influence
Diagnostics can help guide subsequent
procedures if we can definitively
identify influenza and provide a
diagnosis does it prevent subsequent
tests orders lab orders and even
procedures imaging and things like that
we know it's helpful to the medical
staff and helping to predict course as
well as with any diagnostic modality we
know that if we can help to predict a
course and with the diagnosis that it's
helpful to families in the communities
so we know that there are a number of
reasons to test for influenza to help
predict cohort and hospitals and it's
useful for patients to know as well so
there are a number of reasons to test
for flu but again we come back to this
central issue does any of the testing
that we do make a difference and that's
going to be a central theme going
forward so there are many things that we
can do in the clinical laboratory
testing is one of them this is just one
of the photos that I saw last year at a
local grocery store that I thought I'd
share with you we all have our part in
helping with influenza season this is
just one of them but beyond that in the
laboratory we clearly have an armament
now of ways to test for influenza virus
new tools that are disposable that we
frankly have never had before from the
large multiplex viral panels to
pcr-based tests to the new generation of
rapid assays to our point of care
deliveries to even cell culture and
direct fluorescent antigen based tests
what is the proper way to test for flu
remains a theoretical discussion and is
largely dependent on variables that
influence one's own healthcare system
but this is just some of the armament
that is at our disposal for how we test
for
when one looks at the data we can see
that not all testing is equivalent this
was a study performed a few years ago by
Christine ginocchio in New York looking
at the sensitivities in 2009 again this
was the height of the h1n1 outbreak of
some of the rapid tests that were at
there in bed their disposal at the time
of looking at it and you can see that
not all tests performed equally the
other thing that you note is that it's
very difficult to argue for testing that
meets a minimum sensitivity bar below
fifty percent it's very difficult to
argue for that testing and part of the
reason I'm showing this slide is this
slide was really a see a key Sentinel
slide in my career in terms of being
able to advocate for a way of the use of
the rapids on campus I've since come a
little bit softer and full circle on the
use of some of the newer generation
rapid assays but you can see that not
all testing is performed equal well what
about the use of the rapid panel tests
the comprehensive tests that can look
for 1617 in some cases 21 different
circulating respiratory viruses these
assays clearly have a role in our
diagnostic armamentarium and we use them
for our inpatient admissions our
transplant units are areas in which we
need to know definitively the
circulating virus composition
independent in a potential patient this
is just one additional publication done
by Melissa Miller's group in the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
looking at some of the sensitivity of
some of the multiplex panel based
testing in this series they looked at
sensitivity as a comparison of two of
the three positive nucleic acid tests
that could detect an assay detect a
virus and once again you see that these
test platforms perform very well but you
can notice that it takes time to get
these results and the actionable event
on being able to diagnose influenza
virus when the patient is in front of
you is limited by the use of these tests
so the debate over the ideal influenza
test I've used this quote borrowed this
quote stole this quote from some
colleagues of mine who have published on
CDF related issues but we're reminded
from Wyatt Earp that fast is fine but
accuracy is everything and we're really
looking for diagnostic assays that can
provide us with an
actionable event with a standalone
result that we know is definitive so
over the years the testing in the debate
for the ideal influenza test has
typically been a balance between
sensitivity and speed over the last few
years that debate has typically debated
over how much are we willing to pay as
not only laboratories but as healthcare
systems for the access to the speed of
that testing and where that testing is
more or less likely to result in
actionable events I'm putting this slide
up here just as a reminder this is the
CDC's guidance to professionals to
clinician guidance for algorithms for
looking at the way in which we determine
the use of rapid influenza testing and
you can see from this figure here that
they're basically letting us know that
where the test is positive and where the
test is negative that we should be
looking at signs and symptoms once again
advocating for the use of the clinical
direction because we know some of our
rapid tests have historically lacked the
sensitivity that we've come to expect
from the larger core laboratory
facilities who can offer the testing so
that brings us to the point of the new
test that we like to show you this is a
new test on the market some of you have
heard of this test the cobas Elliot test
and this is a new test presented by
roche the next few slides are courtesy
of roche provided to me from roche to
kind of elaborate and illustrate what
the test is so the test is a standalone
analyzer it is a molecular true cycling
pcr that actually cycles in a molecular
platform a pencil-sized flexible tube is
inserted into the instrument the tube
can only go in you one directional
unidirectional we fill it up with the
viral transport media that we use to
inoculate the two that we collect from
from suspension the interesting thing
about this essay is that this essay uses
a actuator with all chemicals stored on
board that allow us to be able to cycle
at a very very rapid rate that rate
allows us to be able to offer a
molecular test a reverse transcriptase
pcr for influenza virus in less than a
25-minute less than a 30-minute
threshold the two analytical test time
for detection of influenza on the
instrument is
approximately 20 to 22 minutes and it's
this actuation process that allows the
cooling and thermal cycling processes to
really be sped up to the point where it
can break that 30-minute threshold for
those of you that know what I'm talking
about when we brought about molecular
tests we often think about cycles of
molecular tests and historically we've
been looking at one degrade per ampere
degree per second that sounds very
technical what are we talking about we r
44 typical 40 to 45 cycle or 30 to 35
cycle assay we're typically restricted
to one minute per cycle which typically
allows our molecular assays to be
offered at somewhere around that 35 45
50 minute threshold this technology
allows us to speed that process up quite
substantially it's got heating and
cooling elements controlled temperatures
motion sensors in the assay that are all
preset the optical system then can read
individual channels for both an
influenza A and influenza B target as
well as an internal control that is all
on board in the test the test is fully
complete it packs everything that you
need to be able to run the PCR reaction
it's one stop closed tube system that
includes all the magnetic bead based
extractions the lysis buffer is the
proteinase k the elution buffer is and
all the pcr reagents required to do PCR
all in a flexible platform single tube a
device the company currently has claims
for both strep a as well as influenza
A&B on the system so the key question
that I want to keep circling down to is
can access to rapid reliable molecular
based influenza testing in the emergency
department change practice management so
when we heard about access to this test
we can't we contracted some of the folks
through the independent grant
association that Roche carries to be
able to look at a grant that would allow
us to sample the use of the test in a
high-throughput emergency department
setting Hennepin County Medical Center
has a very large very well-known
national emergency medicine to program
urgency medicine department we see
roughly 110 thousand ED visits a year
and we thought it would be a good
opportunity to look at the use of
modern contemporary diagnostics so we
got together a group that we formed into
a study that we referred to as the clade
study the clinical decision making in
the emergency department setting using
the use of this test at the
patient-centered level so we are
fortunate enough to have a laboratory
emergency department laboratory it's run
under the larger laboratory CLIA license
many of you have an emergency department
or a satellite lab associated with your
emergency department we looked at it
over three months during the 2015 season
in approximately 314 patient visits we
were fortunate enough to be able to tap
into the medical students and the
residents that are associated with our
Hospital in University of Minnesota that
allowed us to incorporate a 24-7 study
enrollment the best way to interpret
whether or not a test is actually making
a difference in actionable events for a
position is to simply ask them so our
medical students and residents were
fortunate enough to feed them and
provide them with the opportunity to be
involved in a study were able to
admission administer a five-page
surveyed to the admitting physician when
a patient came in we had 150 patients
enrolled in the series that provided a
in addition to the history and physical
a detailed study five page survey was
administered that asked the provider
very key specific questions what is the
likelihood of flu in your patient what
symptoms does your patient have what is
your initial management course are you
going to give them antipyretics are you
going to admit them are you going to
give them imaging are you going to order
chest films are you going to provide
antimicrobials are you going to give
them Tamiflu very specific pointed
questions related to their history and
physical exam that we could track the
changes that were made in patient
management as a result of the test so as
the study was it being administered and
the survey was being given we were
running the influenza test in the
emergency department clinical lab we
included cases that met our 45 minute
bar window which allowed us to look at
150 patients when the test result from
the lab came back the same provider that
provided the initial history and
physical and provided the initial
assessment was
a follow-up survey and asked did the
result of rapid influenza test change
anything on your management and test
characteristics of the assay were
performed compared to the gen mark assay
to look at all the analytics that the
lab community likes to look at
sensitivity specificity but we were
really interested in looking at is
whether or not the clinicians could
document changes in as a result in
management of their patients as a result
of the test now it's important to know
that all of the changes that were
documented by the provider in the second
follow-up survey had to be traceable to
the electronic medical record I'm not a
big fan of survey based studies because
anybody can frankly do them and they're
often biased the og dr. Hansen is a good
guy I know a few people in the emergency
department I'll click yes on his survey
and so we needed to track that any
changes that a provider noted could be
traced directly to the medical record
what do I mean by that well if a
provider said I'm going to admit the
patient because I'm very concerned about
the influenza status in the patient and
the test result came back and was
influenza negative and the provider
decided why I think you could probably
go home we don't probably need to admit
you based on your influenza status that
change had to be documented in epic we
needed to be able to go which is our
electronic medical record we needed to
be able to go back into the electronic
medical record and see the initial order
for an antibiotic and antiviral and
admission and then see that order
changed in order to count it in our
study so how do we know how test has an
impact these are some of the questions
that were asked to the providers upon
the initial presentation of the patient
in the emergency department with
influenza-like symptoms we asked about
the clinical suspicion for flu we asked
about the clinical symptoms does your
patient have fever do we see hemoptysis
do we see some of these issues that
associate with the influenza like
illness what is on your history and
physical differential what else is
included in your in your differential
other than influenza does this person
have an exacerbation of COPD what is
your initial care and plan for the
patient are you going to administer
therapy are you going to administer
procedures and do you plan to admit the
patient when the test result returned a
pointed series of 15 targeted questions
were asked to providers based on the
initial assessment this is just some of
the questions that were asked did the
influence of the influenza test change
your management will an admission
discharge order be changed will a
patient receive anti therapeutic agents
in a different form now will you add
additional lab tests will you DC
additional lab tests to get an
indication of how the tests being
delivered in a fashion within a 40 45
minute timeframe could impact management
of influenza patients in the emergency
department setting and this is some of
our results what we noticed was that in
a hundred and fifty documented patients
we saw changes in patient management in
almost sixty percent of the cases fifty
percent of the time the providers noted
a change that could be documented to the
electronic medical record as a result of
having access to rapid influenza testing
in the emergency department setting the
other thing that's somewhat interesting
but probably not surprising to the
laboratory community is that over half
of those cases in which a management
change occurred in a patient were as a
result of a negative influenza test and
there's lots of discussion these days
about point of care for microbiology
about where we are likely to best
operationalize our resources are limited
resources in healthcare dollars in
laboratory expenditure and in laboratory
personnel but the best candidate for a
test in which we can make an argument
for is a test that has clinical decision
points resulting on both positive and
negative test results so what this
figure shows here is that over half 61
percent of the cases in which a
management change was documented
occurred as a result of confidence in a
negative influenza test result so what
were the changes that we had seen and
what were the changes that were
documented by the providers recordable
in the electronic medical record well
not surprisingly fifty-three percent of
the documented changes to antiviral anti
stewardship occurred the way that we use
our anti-infective agents is largely
dependent on the accuracy and the
timeliness in which the laboratory can
deliver diagnostic results for
infectious related issues seventeen
percent of our changes also occurred in
changes to admission order sets either
patients were not going to be initially
admitted or they were going to be
initially admitted and the result of the
influenza test in conjunction with the
larger clinical picture allowed
providers to change order sets for
admission or discharge and we'll talk
about the significance of that finding
in a few slides nineteen percent of the
changes that we saw occurred in changes
to procedures in the lab as you can see
sometimes this goes both ways if we
diagnose influenza sometimes it results
in additional tests being ordered where
now we have additional chest films being
ordered because we're concerned about
pneumonia so there are nineteen percent
of the cases that we saw we saw changes
to additional procedures and additional
orders we have one case in our series
for note in which the differential
included meningitis on a
fourteen-year-old girl that came into
the emergency department upon testing
for influenza the clinical team decided
that the positive influenza result
probably negated a spinal tap on that
individual so you can see the cascade of
events that occur as the result of
access to positive and negative test
results in the system I mentioned this
before that this is an example of one of
the figures from the CDC's initiative to
healthcare providers of how to deal with
influenza during the influenza season
and you can see here that this is a
question that we've asked is can
clinical symptoms impression alone
diagnose influenza with any degree of
accuracy why do we need laboratory
testing at all we hear it every year
from colleagues from providers from
guideline based approaches if a patient
presents with influenza like illness the
likelihood during flu season that that
person has flu is probably pretty strong
do we really even need testing at all to
be able to diagnose influenza and you
see even with the guidance from the CDC
based on some of the difficulties with
the rapid test results the actionable
events are to use clinical signs and
symptoms and history as information with
which patient management approaches will
continue for patients that have
influenza so a philosophical question
would be if we added up all these
clinical symptoms alone how well would
providers do in diagnosing influenza
well because our survey asked that
question directly what is the likelihood
that your patient has influenza we were
actually able to go back and chart that
and what we found was when providers
indicated that this patient fell into a
very high risk and I think the
probability of this patient having
influenza based on clinical symptoms
alone was high it turns out they were
right only thirty-six percent of the
time we know that looking at fever gave
us a clinical sensitivity during last
year's flu season of only thirty percent
and that the clinical sensitivity of no
fever was almost identical so what does
all of this data mean does this mean
that providers are only thirty-six
percent sensitive and diagnosing flu
from clinical symptoms alone well
there's lots of debates to have from
this but it's interesting to remember
our experience in our study of
thirty-six percent sensitivity because
that number is exactly the same as a
very recent publication done out of
Johns Hopkins that looked at the exact
same issue when they looked at back and
looked at the clinicians perspective of
the clinical diagnosis and how well the
clinical diagnosis correlated to Ana
diagnosis of influenza based on a gold
standard of lab testing sensitivity
thirty-six percent is the exact same
number that we found in our series so
it's food for thought it's paused for
caution perhaps that the clinical
symptoms that we're seeing each year
with changes in influenza status really
are difficult for providers in very high
risk areas and very large areas where
we're trying to triage patients through
with any degree of accuracy uncertainty
in this series here the ili the
influenza like case definition was less
sensitive than the clinical diagnosis
but still did not approach fifty percent
so our experience the raw laboratory
analytical experience we're still kind
of debating some of the the correlative
data of this there's a couple discrepant
sweer looking at but we had three
hundred and fourteen cases that we were
able to analyze a hundred and fifty of
those cases met our patient criteria for
being able to have clinical
documentation changes tracked through
the electronic medical record but we
have three hundred fourteen cases in
which we looked at the cobas layout /
flu season last year including 82
positive three of them we used the gin
mark RVP panel dr. Miller as I showed
earlier in a slide has previously shown
that that panel is a very sensitive very
specific a say on the market and you can
see that anytime you do a comparative
study there's a couple of stragglers
that we have to work out here we're
still in the process of looking at those
to see whether or not those are sample
distribution issues if we would just we
split the specimen too many times or
whether or not there was actually
influenza RNA in the sample but the
sensitivity of our assay performed very
well the sensitivity of the package
insert from the manufacturers is shown
before as well where we can see
sensitivity of a hundred percent for
both flew a and flew be it's also
important to note strong sensitivity of
flu being historically many of the
assays on the market including ones that
I've used in our practice have faltered
with sensitivities of flu be flu be
often becomes a more difficult
diagnostic target to look at it's also
potentially a more difficult treatment
target to look at as well there's a
number of very well done series
including a very well-done study in
Tokyo looking at the efficacy of the
antiviral treatment for influenza B and
a statistically lower and clinically
significant lower rate than we see for
influenza A so when you look at
sensitivity of the assays that you're
looking at influenza A and influenza B
sensitivity is important to understand
the impact of co circulating viruses is
also a hot topic we've learned much
about the role of co circulating viruses
we thought we'd share this with you we
found a respiratory virus which included
flu but a respiratory virus in
over half percent over fifty three
percent of all of the cases we
encountered the emergency department
last year so we are starting to see the
impact of some of these circulating
virus a slide like this points to the
value of being able to understand what
viruses are actually present in our very
very sick patients are very compromised
patients are transplant patients the
influenza virus was detected in 44 of
all of the cases we encountered and a
second respiratory virus was detected in
over a quarter of all of the cases we
had seen the e the ED physicians
involvement in the assay and in
diagnostic testing is really important
as well and so we were able to go back
prospectively and ask the providers in
real time about the satisfaction of the
test that they were looking at
satisfaction is becoming kind of a hot
term we're looking at it in regards to
patient satisfaction but also provider
satisfaction in terms of the services
that we deliver from the lab not
surprisingly we had a very strong
support of the test in our emergency
department what's really interesting to
me about the patient satisfaction
responses are the cases in which we
found providers were not happy with the
test most of those incidences were
around cases in which the test result
could not be delivered within the 35 to
45 minute period and it's one thing to
keep in mind as we bring tests like this
into our environment is that most of
these are single box tests that require
us to put one sample in at a time so
when we look at the way in which we
deliver influenza testing in our
communities and on our practice we need
to be cognizant of surge capacity and
the ability for us to get assays on the
market and get samples through that meet
certain degrees of volume that we were
expect to see in certain areas so what
does all this mean we talked about the
analytical sensitivity we talked about
the value of testing we even showed you
some of the data that proved that the
testing that we had performed in the
emergency department last year had
clinically actionable events but there
are two key questions that need to be
asked the first is is what is the affair
of all this testing on our health care
dollars and is smarter expenditure
really a solution so I'm going to give
you a little bit of insight into some
data that we're continuing to mine as
part of our study that we hope to be
able to present at the Association for
molecular pathology meeting in a couple
of months we know from some very large
studies done and funded by the AHRQ that
have looked at the cost for hospital
stays in the United States this is a
very difficult slide to read but this
little purple arrow here highlights the
fact that we're seeing positive
admissions increases in admission for
patients that have codes for pneumonia
and we're seeing pneumonia become a
larger larger issue in our hospital
systems over the last couple years we
know that there's almost a seven percent
increase in hospital stays that include
a diagnosis of pneumonia from an
emergency department setting so there
are a number of ways in which hospitals
bill and recoup costs associated with
pneumonia we also know from another very
well done AHRQ document that the average
cost of admitting somebody with a simple
diagnosis of pneumonia that would
exclude TB that would exclude HIV a
simple diagnosis of pneumonia from an
emergency department setting typically
costs a healthcare organization about
ten thousand dollars a diagnosis we know
that there are a number of drg codes
that we can apply to diagnosis to allow
hospital systems to be able to recoup
costs associated with a initial
diagnostic grouping code the complexity
of these codes add various values to
what hospitals are essentially allowed
to charge allowed to bill and you can
see some of the numbers here but some of
them you clearly note that what we can
recoup is less than what the AHRQ is
established as the principal diagnosis
of pneumonia if we're costing on the
cost of a hospital bed is ten thousand
dollars for the simple admission and we
can only recoup five thousand dollars of
that you can see that it's costing us
more money in this current healthcare
climate to treat patients than what
hospitals can recoup so where does this
all come in
well this is some data that we're
working on with a health care economics
group to look at health care nomics
economics outcomes associated with the
data set that we were able to generate
but just to show you superficially some
of the incidents that we're looking at
is we're looking at the use of tests as
cost aversion cost diversion tools in
our total healthcare dollars where can
we reallocate healthcare dollars in a
more clinically responsible financially
responsible fashion we know that the
simple cost of a diagnosis for pneumonia
is about ten thousand dollars a case in
the 65 days we performed our analysis 15
documented cases were seen where
hospital admission changes were changed
where we would have admitted a patient
but that patient was now discharged as
part of the larger clinical picture
including the access to the rapid
influenza result if you just do some
simple math you start to see how the
numbers start to generate where you can
potentially look at a cost diversion of
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
65 days in a very high emergency
department high throughput high incident
season of influenza we also know that
the court the ability to judiciously use
our antivirals and anti-infectives also
has a role every hospital now likely has
antimicrobial stewardship committees
that have been gathered that have been
mandated in many cases by CMS by jaicko
by regulatory authorities to look at the
way in which antimicrobials are provided
and given and used at healthcare
facilities so the ability for diagnostic
tests to either confirm or support the
original use of anti-infectives is
important as well and we estimate the 33
cases of Tamiflu fact we documented 33
cases of Tamiflu or deseed in our in our
65 day trial with use of the test which
had a cost to version of over another
three thousand dollars so we're looking
at the ways in which testing can help
with costs diversion in in our overall
health care dollars so the summary and
conclusions we know that rapid access to
sensitive flu testing in the emergency
department environment was associated
with changes
and patient management's to both a
clinically significant and a
statistically significant level we know
that fifty-three percent of the
documented changes we observed in our
series involve changes to anti-infective
treatment and the changes in admission
and discharge orders accounted for
seventeen percent of all the evaluable
cases but those seventeen percent were
the largest cost diversions that we
could have obtained in our series and
that twenty-three percent of all the
documented changes in initial management
occurred as a result of access to rapid
flu testing so the cobas liase truly
represents a rapid sensible sensitive
adaptable assay for the delivery of
influenza results that can impact
patient care it's somewhat ironic that
for the last decade laboratory
communities have been clamoring for a
rapid adaptable molecular standalone
result box stand alone assay that would
allow us to deliver testing in
clinically actionable events closer to
patients and now we have one on the
market so my final thoughts as we get to
the end of this presentation are just to
talk about the philosophical barriers of
point of care applications for influenza
testing there's no question that the
delivery of healthcare and our current
climate is about to change we're looking
at models that are based on preventative
medicine rather than to have people
present to our hospitals in many cases
if people present to our emergency
departments we've done a bad job can we
prevent actionable events in larger
settings outside of the traditional
models of where we typically looked at
where testing is done ie a core
centralised molecular or microbiology
laboratory and to remind us of where
we've come and the potential of where we
might go we look back to the early 90s
of where we were with point-of-care
testing and post-anesthesia care units
as a result of access to blood gases two
sodium's two potassium's and very well
done studies that showed that the
analytical transport time really was a
barrier in terms of being able to
deliver accurate results to patients
history
correctly for Microbiology our barrier
in our bar has been our familiarity in
our comfort level with the sensitivity
and the specificity of the testing that
we allowed to leave the laboratory but
these discussions are worth having
there's lots of testing there's plenty
of testing to go around the discussions
of we're testing is more likely to
provide actionable events are key
discussion points going forward for both
the laboratory but specifically the
microbiology community going forward so
the final thoughts is access to testing
enough to impact patient outcome it's
the integration of test results with the
physician at the bedside at the level at
which the history in the physical is
being provided that really provided
actionable events in our series in order
for point-of-care to provide a tangible
clinical benefit its results should be
actionable and used to make decisions
which lead to improved healthcare
outcome and systems like the kobus Leah
offer us the potential of offering us
testing in areas in which we
historically been limited I'm citing a
very very well-known quote by Harry
gallus and the folks in the University
of North Carolina over well over 20
years ago 1999 in which the authors
noted that central to the concept of
empiric management is uncertainty
regarding the diagnosis the role that we
have in the laboratory to help be part
of the larger clinical picture to impact
patient care is a real role and our data
set proves that that the data that's
delivered from the laboratory is used to
make clinical decision and the data
that's provided by laboratory ins makes
a difference so with that the barriers
to implementation are probably a
discussion point to be had in a separate
discussion what is the cost of this
testing how do we look at surge capacity
where do we see testing evolving from
but clearly our experience has shown us
that the actionable events in the
emergency department with access to
rapid influenza testing changed practice
management so with that we feel we've
got a new test on the market a new
system on the market that offers us of
advantage we've never had before in the
fight against influenza there are many
ways to tackle influenza and now we
believe we
another diagnostic tool on the forefront
so with that I want to thank everybody
for their time their discussions and
allowing me to share our data set with
you today thank you very much thank you
dr. Hansen for that interesting
presentation bringing that information
to us about flu and flu testing before
we get started with audience questions I
just want to remind our attendees how to
reach us today questions can be sent via
the Greek you a button for lower left of
the presentation window and you know
hopefully we can get to as many
questions as we can we don't then we'll
definitely follow up with you via email
so let me just check in our give our
audience just a minute to type in
questions see what they have to say okay
I'm not seeing anything from the
audience that's okay I'm sure we'll get
follow-up via email the presentation
will be available on demand I'd like to
Pat it back to dr. Hansen and ask him if
he has any final thoughts or comments on
today's topic sure I think that one of
the things that I would stress is the
opportunity for clinical communities to
get together to look at the way in which
our testing is delivered to patients I
think our experience is just one
experience but it certainly influenced
the way in which we feel that influenza
in our emergency department really needs
to be examined and we're entering into
frontiers here that are new for the
laboratory so I think it's important
that we look at with a critical eye of
new tests that come on the market we ask
very important clinical questions but
also larger questions about where our
health care dollars are best spent this
is an exciting time for the laboratory
as new platforms come to the market and
this is just one of them so I encourage
of those of us in the field to talk to
each other to share experiences and to
ask questions it's clearly not a
one-size-fits-all discussion so
experiences from other people are
helpful in the discussion of how
we test for flu in the influenza season
where we commit to spend our healthcare
dollars and so forth so that would be my
final thought for the for the entire
community here good thoughts good to
hear dr. Hansen thank you again for
sharing your time with us I also want to
thank our sponsor roche diagnostics for
making it possible to bring this
presentation to you and as I said before
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through februari 2016
you'll receive an email from lab roots
to let you know when it's available for
on-demand and posted on lab routes comm
we welcome you to furl with this
announcement to any colleagues who are
not able to join in today in the live
event thank you again for logging on and
participating in today's broadcast from
nine see you next time